>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Sabrina Baron:
Welcome, everyone,
to the November meeting of
the Washington area group
for print culture studies.
This will be our last
meeting in this calendar year
and we'll pick up again in
February and we will meet
in February, March, and
April in the spring.
So we hope you'll try to join us
for those if you're interested.
We have a reflector list if
anybody is here who's not
on the reflector list and you'd
like to hear about our meetings,
you talk to myself or Allen
and we can get you on the list.
We keep it deactivated so you
don't get spammed through that,
if you'd like to
be on that list.
Anything else, there's
been so much going
on in the past couple of weeks.
So, after the talk we have to
clear out of here pretty much
at five o'clock on a Friday and
after the talk we go for drinks
and dinner with the speaker and
if you'd like an opportunity
to continue conversations
with the speaker,
that's a very good
opportunity to do that
and it's always a
very congenial group
that goes for that as well.
So, if you'd like to join us,
we'd like to invite
anyone who's interested
to come along and join us.
And so we're very pleased today
to have Anthony Lee who's
been a member of this group --
and he has a handout
if you didn't get it there
are some copies by the door --
who's been a member of our group
and he's going to talk to us
about Johnson's Dictionary and
some well-known literary figures
and Eleanor will give Tony a
more detailed introduction.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: Thank you,
thank you very much
we are very pleased
to have Anthony Lee here today.
His research centers on
Samuel Johnson and his circle,
mentoring and intertextuality.
He has published three books and
more than 30 essays on Johnson
and 18th century
literature and culture.
He has three more books
forthcoming, very busy.
One is Community and Solitude:
New Essays on Johnson's Circle
with Becknell Press and
that's coming out in 2018.
Modernity Johnson: Samuel
Johnson Among the Modernists
and that's coming out
Thompson University Press 2019.
In addition, he is currently
serving a self-imposed life
sentence editing The
Annotated Rambler.
Anthony has taught at
a number of colleges
and universities including
The University of Arkansas,
Arkansas Tech, The University
at Kentucky Wesleyan College,
The University of the District
of Columbia, and The University
of Maryland University College
where he also served as director
of English and Humanities
programs.
Today's talk draws upon
two pieces scheduled
for publication in 2018.
One will appear in Notes
and Queries and the other
in The Johnsonian's Newsletter.
So.
>> Anthony Lee: Thank
you, thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
And I'd like to thank
Eleanor and Sabrina for --
I'm not supposed to stray
too far from this --
Eleanor and Sabrina for
offering me the opportunity
to have a conversation with
you about Samuel Johnson.
And I'd also like to thank
a former student of mine,
Debra Carson and her husband
John, who drove up here,
or down here I should say
from New Jersey to be here
so I'm very grateful that
they made the time to do that.
I'm going to start with
a brief description
of an underlying premise of
this paper and then I'm going
to talk a little bit about
the methodological terminology
and then I'm going to plunge
into the narrative itself.
So the underlying
premise, my approach --
also, my talk is fairly
detailed, textually,
so I'll have reference
to the handout and also
to the high points, so hopefully
that will help you
navigate the details.
My approach will be to
look at small things,
things typically considered
marginal, both literally,
mottos which occupy the
margins of the page,
and figuratively
unimportant by some people.
It is my hope by the time that
I am done here that some of you,
perhaps, will be persuaded to
agree with Detective Somerset,
who's quoted on the handout,
and one of my mottos,
"Postulate that we should seek
to find one item, one detail,
until it becomes an
inexhaustible possibility."
And that's a wonderful -- it's
a very grizzly and gory movie,
but it's a wonderful
movie and Somerset is
like a literary critic.
I mean, literally, he
uses Dante and Chaucer
to help uncover the criminal,
but I think he provides a good
model for us literary critics
who look for clues and try
to come up with hypotheses
and find what ultimately
may be the truth.
So, the methodological
parameters, French theorist
and critic, Gerard Genette
has developed the concept
of transtextuality, which is
his general inclusive term
for the relationships
between a text and other text.
He has identified five
transtextual regimes,
two of which I will
use here today.
The first is on your
handout; intertextual,
a relation of co-presence
between two or more texts,
most often by the literal
presence of one text
within the other and these
typically consist of quotations,
allusions, plagiarism,
among other things.
And the second term that I
want to use is paratextual,
that is the luminal devices
and conventions both within
and outside of the book that
mediate it to the reader
and these would include titles,
forewords, dedications, notes,
epigraphs, epilogues, et
cetera, among many other things.
And for us today the
salient example is the motto,
the periodical essay motto.
So, we shall plunge
into the narrative.
Today I want to look
primarily at two texts,
two Johnsonian texts; The
Dictionary and The Rambler.
The Rambler, as I'm
sure many of you know,
is a series of 208 periodical
essays that Johnson composed
between 1750 and 1752.
They are considered by
many people, perhaps me,
to be his greatest work.
Other contenders would be
The Lives of the Poets and,
for some people, Rasselas,
in terms of his literary
production.
But I go back and forth
between them myself,
but I'm editing The Rambler,
I have to stick with that one.
And then, of course,
The Dictionary probably
needs no introduction
to a learned audience
such as this.
And Johnson was working on
both of these simultaneously.
The Dictionary between 1747 and
'55 and The Rambler, as I said,
'50-'52, so there is
some interesting overlap
and interpenetration
between the two.
So, we'll begin specifically
by looking at Rambler Number 2,
which is on the necessity and
danger of looking into futurity.
Following The Spectator,
Johnson used classical mottos
to introduce his essays.
In many respects he may be seen
as following in the footsteps
of Addison and Steele, despite
the significant differences
separating their respected
periodical projects,
the motto in both served as a
textual portal into the essay
as an oblique pracey [phonetic].
Given the close association
of the motto with the epigram,
proverb, maxim, et cetera,
genres with strong
moral connotations,
the motto melds snugly
with Johnson's overriding
ethical emphasis.
The one that I've singled
out to look at today is taken
from the Latin Silver Age poet,
Statius, from his epic, Thebaid,
and the handout should
have a prose translation,
"To stand still is torture,
a thousand paces are
wasted before the start.
The heavy hoof strikes
the absent flag.
Both The Spectator and The
Rambler were aimed primarily
at a literate middle
class audience.
Many of the readers would have
known Latin, but many would not,
and even less would
have known Greek.
And so the classical
models may have been adopted
to lend an aura of
intellectual prestige
to the essays that followed.
Nonetheless, many of the readers
would require translation.
Lists were soon provided
with English translations
and for Johnson and The
Rambler, the first was compiled
by a man named James Elphinston,
a Scott from Edinburgh
who began publishing while
The Rambler as still going on,
in the same year,
what was called --
what is called The Edinburgh,
or the Second Edition,
in six untitled volumes.
And in volume one of
this edition at the end,
the volume one contains
essays one through 26,
would publish the
mottos in English.
Little is known about the early
relationship between Johnson
and -- I think I -- yeah,
there's the Edinburgh edition --
and this is actually
a very rare edition.
There's only a few copies known
in the world so this is taken
from the second issue, actually,
which is much less rare.
Not a whole lot is known about
the relationship between the two
at this early stage,
but apparently Johnson,
in a letter to Elphinston gave
his tacit approval to Elphinston
to do this edition and
to translate the mottos.
Rambler 2 exemplifies, the
translation of the model
from Rambler 2, exemplifies
an Elphinston translation
that Johnson, at least
initially, approved,
but later had second
thoughts about.
It is virtually unrecognizable
as Statius,
it's more of a summary,
verse summary,
of the essay as a whole.
"Fond fleeting Hope, with
prospects ne'er destroy'd,
Roams ere she flies,
defeated while enjoy'd."
Gentleman's magazine
for September 1750
printed translations
for the first 30 Ramblers
and these are clearly
from the Edinburgh edition
although it's not stated.
The next edition, which I think
should be called the third
edition, but actually the great
Johnson bibliographer David
Fleeman, denominates the
second London edition.
Six volumes in Dewey
Decimal appeared in 1752,
this one also lists motto
translations on a separate sheet
at the end of the last volume.
But here we discern change.
Johnson drops Elphinston's
fumbling verses
and replaces them with two
couplets from Alexander Pope,
"Th' impatient courser pants
in ev'ry vein, And pawing seems
to beat the distant plain;
Hills, vales, and floods,
appear already crost,
And, e'er he starts,
a thousand steps are lost."
And then in 1756, what's called
the fourth edition was published
in four volumes and this
one is also extremely rare.
This is the last edition
revised by Johnson personally
and it had served,
controversially,
for the copied text
for the Yale edition
of the works of Samuel Johnson.
So, are there any Pope
readers in the audience?
Specialists?
You don't notice
anything unusual?
Okay, you have a
convenient excuse.
Anybody notice anything
unusual about this translation?
You would have to be a
Pope specialist to do so.
It actually is from a poem that
he wrote, an original poem,
called Windsor-Forest, 1713.
And this is from the manuscript
which was published in 1752,
and there are the
verses up close.
>> [ Inaudible ]
>> Pope is famous for
practicing what's called
representative verse.
Yeah, the sound imitates
the sense.
And Johnson talks about that
number of times, particularly
in The Life of Pope, taking
issue with it, actually.
So if he were here today he
may be disagreeing with you.
So Johnson was also --
you mentioned mentoring --
Johnson was a great mentor,
famously generous
to younger authors.
And he helped John Hawkesworth
launch a periodical series;
The Adventurer, patterned
closely upon The Rambler,
which Johnson vigorously
promoted and to
which he contributed some 29
essays and a number of mottos.
One of the essays, number 45, he
recurs to the Statius passages
that we're looking
at, number 45.
So he does it again,
he takes a Latin tag,
provides a translation
that's, apparently,
not really a translation;
however,
there is an explanation,
that's why I'm bringing it up.
In 1751, seven years after
Pope's death, William Warburton,
his friend and apologist,
who made his career
on Pope's skirt tails,
edited a nine volume edition
of Pope's works and, of course,
Windsor-Forest was
included in it.
And he pens a note,
or a line, verse 151,
and I think this is
on your handout, too.
So, I'll go ahead and read this.
"These lines Mr. Dryden, in
his preface to his translation
of Fresnoy's Art of painting,
calls wonderfully fine,
and says they would cost him
an hour, if he had the leisure
to translate them, there is so
much of beauty in the original;
which the reason why, I suppose,
why Mr. P. tried his
strength with them."
So the Windsor-Forest passage
is, in fact a translation,
from the lines of
Statius's Thibead.
According to Pope's
bibliographer,
Reginald Harvey Griffith,
the Warburton edition
appeared in June of that year.
During the following year,
the second London edition
of The Rambler began
appearing in January 1752
and the sixth volume containing
the list of translations
at the end that first used
the Windsor-Forest lines was
advertised in July 1752
in Gentleman's Magazine.
So the close chronological
proximity suggests
that Johnson read at
least this part of Pope's,
Warburton's edition
and appropriated it
for his translation.
In addition to identifying the
lines as an actual quotation,
Warburton goes on to make
an important point, I think,
how Dryden's off-hand
comment spurred Pope
to do what his poetic master
disdained or neglected to do.
The Dryden-Pope relationship
is a classic example
of what I elsewhere talked
about as symbolic mentoring,
where a writer is mentored
by another writer whom
they never actually meet.
An older author, but whose
work has a profound influence
on them.
So the Warburton note exhibits,
from my perspective, a pregnant
and representative
example of the phenomenon;
for it combines the energies of
respect and emulation with those
that are gone in competition
that complexly mark these
sort of relationships.
So, on one hand, the protégé is
seeking to emulate the master
and be like the master
and honor the master,
but also to out-do the master,
to prove that this is Bloomian,
a hero-Bloomian theory of
literary relationships.
This is the original site
of the Dryden remarks
and since Warburton
summarized them we don't need
to read them again.
Johnson was familiar
with this passage,
apart from the Warburton
connection.
In the Dictionary, he uses
illustrated quotations,
or what are called authorities,
to illustrate definitions
and this is, perhaps, the
most single contribution
of his Dictionary, this is where
the OED comes from, is this idea
of illustrating a word, through
showing its actual use rather
than trying to use merely
abstract definitions.
And so he quotes from it
under the word, fustian,
the entry for fustian,
in the Dictionary.
And, incidentally,
William K. Whimstat reports
that Johnson quotes 157 times
from Dryden's preface
in his Dictionary.
A total that represents
roughly 38% of all
of the 415 illustrations
taken from the entire work,
which is almost, well it's
more than a third taken
from the preface rather
than the work itself.
And my own analysis shows that
Johnson's Dictionary quotations
from the passage in
which Dryden's citing
of Statius is imbedded
include at least 17 entries,
that is just under 11% of all
the examples from the preface.
So based upon this evidence,
the stretch of prose surrounding
the Statius lines compellingly
commanded Johnson's' attention.
And he refers to it again later
when he's writing
The Life of Dryden.
This is also in your handout.
His, Dryden's, comparison
of the first line of Virgil
with the first of
Statius is not happier.
Virgil, he says,
is soft and gentle
and would have thought
Statius mad
if he had heard him
thundering out [Latin].
Statius, perhaps, heats himself
as he proceeds to exaggerations,
somewhat hyperbolical,
but undoubtedly Virgil
would have been too hasty
if he had condemned him to
straw for one sounding mind.
Of course Virgil was an
important symbolic mentor
to Statius as well
and this index
and their relationship
here, I think is something
that fascinates Johnson
and fascinates me as well.
Incidentally, the first line
of the Statian quotation used
by Pope and Johnson is,
in fact, a misquotation.
It includes a substitution
of Statius's original words
with those from Georgia's
384 [Latin].
So what we witness here is a
case of what might be called,
to borrow a Freudian term,
textural over-determination.
And this tiny little literary
site of the motto of Rambler 2,
we find something
densely saturated
with a number of
literary voices.
And Johnson himself is
implicated in this phenomenon;
for he, in addition to absorbing
it and assimilating it,
deploys it in other of
his writings, elsewhere.
So, thank you for
following along
with that fairly
intricate pursuit.
So what do we make of that?
What's going on here?
I'm going to go out on a limb
here, on dangerous ground
and borrow a term from quantum
physics called entanglement,
which is the OED quotation is on
your first page of your handout,
one of my mottos again.
And I'm not standing up here
telling you I know beans
about quantum physics.
I think I heard that maybe there
are 100 people on the planet
that really know
what's going on?
Maybe that's an underestimate.
I hope no one in here
is one of the hundreds
that will take me
to task for this.
So here's what OED says, "A
correlation between the states
of two separate quantum
systems, such that the behavior
of the two together is
different from the juxtaposition
of the behaviors of
each considered alone.
And so, I think the idea is that
what takes place in one system,
it is entangled with another,
separate, across the universe,
perhaps, they have a reciprocal
effect upon one another,
a change that happens in
one shows up in the other.
That's pretty weird.
But, I'm using the term
metaphorically here to try
and put some kind of
intellectual framework on how
to understand these intertextual
relationships amongst these
various authors that
we're seeing that show
up in the Rambler
and the Dictionary.
So, in my idea, a quantum
system is equivalent to a text,
so you have two texts and you
take something from one text
and move it into the other,
it affects both of
them reciprocally.
In the case of the
motto to Rambler 2
and Pope's Windsor-Forest lines
we see a reciprocal relationship
in which the reading of
one influences our reading
of the other and vice versa.
So we see in the motto
of Johnson's recognition
of an intertextual influence
by Statius upon Pope as well
as the intricate cross-hashings
of all the other authors
that we have identified.
And this is not in the paper,
but I should pause to say here;
it's not incidental that Pope
would be interested in Statius.
He was very much interested in
Statius and translated portions
of Statius and talked about
him in conversation and I think
that Statius, of course,
is a Silver Age poet coming
in the footsteps of
Virgil, Horace, and Ovid,
and somewhat overwhelmed
by that.
In Johnson's account,
clearly Statius doesn't come
out very happy in the
comparison, but you know,
Dryden and Pope are
considered Augustans,
referring to the Augustans,
you know, of the Golden Age.
But in another sense,
they are also belated.
They are also coming after what
Dryden called the giants before
the flood; Shakespeare
and Milton.
So, I think Pope recognized
in Statius a predicament
very similar to his own
where he had these
looming masters and,
you know, what do you do next?
He wanted to -- he was going
to write an epic, he never did.
The Dunciad was the best he
could come up with, Dryden, too.
I think he was going to write
one on King Arthur, but anyway.
Looking at these little
sites here, I think,
expands into the larger insights
that are, from my perspective
at least, worth looking at.
So there -- another
quotation from the first page
of the handout, a motto is
from Derrida, Dissemination,
and he says, "Each
grafted text continues
to radiate back toward the site
of its removal transforming
that, too,
as it affects the
new territory."
And again you have
this reciprocity
where you have two
literary sites
that are mutually
interpenetrating one another
in the way that I
understand entanglement,
the concept, to work.
So --
So we're invited to
consider the important
of Pope's relationships
with Statius,
which I just talked about,
and Dryden, his great master,
as symbolic mentors in both
the construction of his career
and the crafting of his --
specific crafting of his verse.
And, likewise, we read
Johnson differently as well,
Rambler 2's motto reverberates
not only throughout the essay
but auto textually across
Johnson's Oove [phonetic]
as we've seen The
Dictionary, Adventurer,
Lives of the Poets, et cetera.
In Rambler 2, the Pawing
Coursers connote Johnson's
enthusiasm for his periodical
essay, notice it's number two,
he's just getting started.
As he stands at the threshold
of its inception making quote
unquote, "A new entrance
into the -- ," my next three
quotes are all from Rambler 2,
making quote, "A new entrance
into the lettered
world," unquote.
This threshold is Janus-like;
however for it looks back
to earlier writers and prepares
the reader for the quotations
and allusions to come.
In this essay, Horace is
quoted twice after the motto,
Epitias and Cervantes.
If, as Johnson informs
us, "the natural flights
of the human mind are not
from pleasure to pleasure,
but from hope to
hope," which is one
of the great Johnson quotations,
"His practice requires
that the creative endeavors of
the present and the expectations
of the future must be thoroughly
grounded in the wisdom
of the past within the cultural
heritage of ancient Greece
and Rome as well as the European
renaissance, as in Cervantes.
This, I think is the ultimate
meaning of his famous remark
from the last paragraph
of the essay,
"Men more frequently required
to be reminded than informed."
That is to say Johnson's entire
Rambler collection can be
profitably read as a
majestic and sweeping effort
to collect -- to coin or
use Arnold's phrase --
the best that has been thought
and written from antiquity
to the early 18th
century and presented
as a monumental compendium
to his contemporary audience
and also to posterity, to us,
those few of us who
still read him.
And I think these reflections
that I'm offering you
give us some insight
into understanding better
a really famous passage
by T.S. Eliot I'm sure you're
all familiar with, "No poet --
," and this is on your
handout, too, I think, "No poet,
no artist of any art has
complete meaning alone.
What happens when a new
work of art is created is
that something happens
simultaneously to all the works
of art which preceded it.
The existing monuments form an
ideal order among themselves
which is modified by the
introduction of the new,
the really new, work
of art among them.
The existing order is complete
before the new work arrives.
For order to persist after
the supervention of novelty,
the whole existing
order must be,
if ever so slightly, altered.
And so, the relations,
proportions,
and values of each work of art
to the whole are readjusted
in this conformity between
the new and the old."
And that's from tradition
and individual talent.
That's a very well-known quote,
but perhaps a less well-known
one from the German critic,
Herman Meyer, the paratactical
and intertactical
intertanglements we are
observing encourage us to
read text in this new way.
Not as self-contained, isolated,
monads, but rather as points
of articulation within larger
networks of interconnection
and dynamic interaction.
As Herman Meyer has observed,
"In general it might be
maintained that the charm
of the quotation emanates
from a unique tension
between assimilation
and dissimilation:
it links itself closely
with its new environment,
but at the same time
detaches from it,
thus permitting another
world to radiate
into the self-contained
world of the novel.
You know, he's talking primarily
about the European novel.
And Meyer's radiation
is in itself entangled
with Derrida's remark that the
grafted text radiates back.
The two comments operate
reciprocally, moving from text
to intertext, intertext to
text, in a revolving oscillation
that both exemplifies and
illuminates the creation
of intertextual meaning.
If taken in its totality,
which is impossible
for the mortal mind,
the entanglements radiating
amongst all the text
in literary history constitute
a vast and vibrant universe,
an intertextual totality,
which such paratext
as the Rambler motto and
a Dictionary quotation,
offer brief, if tantalizing,
glimpses into a sub specie
aeternitatis universe.
This is purely speculative
on my part,
but something I do believe in.
So, the next question you
might ask is, was Johnson aware
of this intertextual field
that I'm suggesting here?
And I tried to talk about and
discuss over the past 10 years
or so, that Johnson possessed
an acutely intertextual mind,
sensibility.
I think it's indisputable.
He does it all the time.
However, he would
not, I don't think,
sign onto this totality
that I'm postulating.
He wouldn't recognize
the concept quite
in the same ways I do.
So, in a qualified sense, yes,
I think he would acknowledge
that there's a real
validity in terms
of reading him intertextually,
but not as sweepingly as I do.
For example, here's a little
paragraph in the preface
to The Dictionary, which
is on your handout.
"I have sometimes,
though rarely,
yielded to the temptation
of exhibiting a genealogy
of sentiments, by showing how
one author copied the thoughts
and diction of another," and
in my work, I've found that --
I find that -- this adverb
"rarely" is an understatement.
Seems to me he's
doing it all the time.
Not in every Dictionary
entry, for sure,
I mean it is a lexicographical
[phonetic] work,
but he is interested in this
and he is doing it a lot.
So, let me conclude this talk
by looking at two examples
of genealogies from
The Dictionary.
We'll look at two entries;
dispeople/dispeopler and whistle
and we've got a first edition
of The Dictionary over there.
The Smithsonian was
supposed to have it on loan,
but we have it here, and,
well I turned it to whistle,
but somebody obviously has been
flipping through the pages,
but if you want to look
at dispeople/dispeopler
and whistle, they're over there.
Augustan poet, John Gay
dedicated his poem Rural Sports
to his recently acquired
friend, Alexander Pope, in 1713.
The title page in his
1720 version commemorates
the friendship.
This is just the title page of
the works, not the poem itself.
Rural Sports was originally
published in January 1713
and was republished in
revised form later that year.
Gay read Pope's manuscript,
the 1712 manuscript
of Windsor-Forest, he
read a den manuscript
and he adopted elements,
intertextually extracted
elements and used it
to craft his own verse.
And The Dictionary shows
us what he's up to.
So, this is
dispeople/dispeopler.
I won't read the
words out to you.
Because of grammatical
necessity,
one involving the
verb, the other a noun,
Johnson separates the two
passages and yet he manages
to put them directly together on
the page so that the resemblance
between them becomes
rather obvious.
Neither Gay nor Pope's
20th century editors
in the critical editions of Gay
or Pope noted this
borrowing, this comparison.
Guess they should have
read Johnson's Dictionary.
Gay's allusion to Pope is
at, for the latter verses,
denominate tyrant to despoil
the landscape in human cities.
Gay's pike is analog to the
ancient kings as a passage
from Walton's complete Angler
makes clear, "The loose
or pike is the tyrant
of the fresh waters."
Johnson quotes this in his
Dictionary under pickerel weed.
But the two entries also
suggest a back wood extension
of the genealogy immediately
preceding the Pope quotation
and the dispeople entry we
find, "His heart exalts him
in the harm already done so have
its dispeopled Heaven, Milton.
That, of course, is from
Paradise Lost, book seven,
describing the original and
type of the tyrant, Satan.
So not only did Johnson discern
the connection between Pope
and Gay, he provides an
intertext that operates
as the common source for both.
It is thus evident
that used in a way
that carefully examines the
authorities that it exhibits,
The Dictionary enables us to
make discoveries of influence
that enhances our
apprehension of the richness
and intertextual density
of these passages.
And speaking of Milton I'll look
at one more, the whistle entry.
And there we find, again,
Milton and Gay aligned,
"While the plowman near
at hand, whistles o'er
for the land," Milton.
"The plowman leaves the task
of day and, trudging homeward,
whistles on the way," Gay.
The similarity between Allegro
and Rural Sports indicate a
direct influence, apparently one
that caught Johnson's eye and
should also catch ours as well.
The two whistling plowmen
and the context of a walk
on a spring-like day found
in the quotation suggest
that Gay takes Milton
as his intertext.
That both couplets are
immediately followed
by dairy scenes,
Milton's milkmaid blithe
and Gay's strokings
of the damsel's hand strongly
support this identification,
so the Dictionary entry
for whistles also suggest
the importance of Milton
as one of Gay's precursors.
And again, I don't want to
pick on these poor editors,
but this is not found
in the Oxford edition --
Event and Dearing's
edition of Gay.
So in conclusion, this
presentation recommends
that Johnson's Dictionary
may be understood to operate
as a versatile instrument
in the toolbox
of literary criticism,
literary scholarship.
A repository of literary
creative, in its own right,
quite apart from its more
obvious lexicographical
functions and it also urges this
talk that paratextual elements
such as quotations,
mottos, allusions,
and the intertextual network
in which they cohere be
taken more seriously as sites
of literary and critical
activity and power.
My work suggests that Johnson
deploys these connections
in his writings and ways
that demonstrate his
intertextual mastery
of the resting tradition
as well as his creative use
of this tradition to
offer new contributions.
Perhaps in a way that
T.S. Eliot would recognize
and approve had he
deigned to burrow
with the mole-like
tenacity that I pursue.
But this is, too, if I may
be permitted my own allusion,
to compare small
things to great.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Shevlin: We have
time for questions now.
>> Speaker 1: [Inaudible]
Pope quotation from dispeople.
You have Paradise Lost for
Milton, but then you have Pope
and then you have
Rural Sports with Gay.
What was the --
>> Anthony Lee: It's
from Windsor-Forest.
>> Speaker 1: Oh, it
is Windsor-Forest.
>> Anthony Lee: So that would
be an example of Gay looking
at the manuscript and
incorporating it --
the 1712 manuscript --
and incorporating it
into his own poem.
Was that not clear
on the handout?
Sorry about that.
>> Speaker 1: But, I
mean, aside from that,
[inaudible] because there's this
you know common kind of motif
of the tyrant, there,
too, right?
You know, the king, likened
to Satan in Paradise Lost.
I mean, Johnson didn't
have any reservations
about representing the
king in that sort of light.
>> Johnson was once asked about
tyranny, the tyranny of kings,
and he said, "Well, if the
kings go too far the people will
up rise and cut his head off."
So, Johnson has a reputation,
a stereotypical reputation,
although some justification, in
being a high bound conservative,
but -- and I'm not an
expert on his politics --
but I think a conservative
today and a conservative
in the 18th century are
two quite different things
and his attitudes towards
politics are more refreshingly
modern than are given
credit for.
He didn't like George
III, of course,
this was before George III,
this was under George II.
He didn't like George II either.
And he thought that George
III was ill-educated.
Lord Boot, who was his tutor,
Johnson thought he
did a terrible job.
That didn't keep Johnson from
supporting the ministries
under George III's reign
in the 1760s and 1770s
because he did write the
four political tracts:
Taxation No Tyranny, Thoughts
on the Falkland Islands,
The Patriot, False Alarm,
in support of the ministry.
And there may have been
some expectation that he do
that because of the pension
that he was awarded in 1762,
although that was
denied officially.
But privately, he was a
great theoretical advocate
of the political
stability and authority,
particular after the English
civil war, you know which,
there were visible remains of
the conflict, the destruction,
in Staffordshire where
he was born and grew up.
And he would have
feared that more
than anything else, you know.
So, political stability
and the insurer
of that being a strong
monarchy, was important to him,
but he was no improver
of tyrants.
I don't know if that touches
upon what you were asking, but,
yeah, the political
context is kind of curious.
It is something that -- it
gave me pause for thought
when I was thinking
about this presentation.
But, clearly he doesn't
have any qualms
about doing it in
his Dictionary.
>> Anthony Lee: Yes?
>> Eleanor Shevlin:
Couple of things.
This idea of intertextuality,
of course overlaps
with the [inaudible].
It also, I was thinking
how T.S. Eliot was quoted
and everything else and it
reminded me of Charlotte Bronte
who expresses something very
similar when she's speaking
about there comes a time when
an author's work is no longer
his own.
And she's very much talking
about the reworking
and the revamping.
And when she and Reeves
went on to write [inaudible]
and was taken from Bronte and
was rather fearful of her kind
of chutzpah in going to take
from Bronte really meditates
all this idea of borrowing.
In terms of your
presentation and this idea
of intertextuality, too,
we're seeing not just
an intertextuality
with these authors at the time,
but among Johnson's impetus
in thinking for his
own projects.
In other words, it makes
perfect seen that he's --
after kind of thinking this
way and winking and working
with these quotes -- that he's
going to extract that and create
that innovativeness
for the Dictionary.
It just -- so, his work
itself is intertextual,
which is what you were saying.
>> Anthony Lee: That's a good
way to look at the introduction
of authorities into
the Dictionary.
I hadn't quite thought of
it in that respect before,
but you're suggesting that
his interest in genealogies
of sentiment and influence may
have prompted the very notion.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: This
is the way I'm going
to construct these words.
Something about, I'm thinking
of Lives of the Poets.
What do you think his
attitude is towards Pope,
Lives of the Poets, and I'm
thinking of life of the Pope.
There's this strange moment in
Pope -- to me it's strange --
the Lives of the
Poets, when Pope has
to that carriage accident.
Johnson's describing it.
And Johnson almost kind of,
texturally, there's a moment
of kind of textural violence
almost with the way on the page
where Pope falls
from his carriage,
he has this carriage accident.
And the way that
Johnson talks about this
and almost interrupts himself
in the telling of Pope's --
do you know what
I'm speaking about?
It's been a long time since I've
read that, but I'm wondering,
I always thought it
seemed almost like --
and I don't do psychoanalytic
reads --
but almost suppressed
animosity somewhat towards Pope.
I mean, Pope flies out of
this carriage [inaudible]
and in the middle of explaining,
Pope, and he has Pope,
which he has exacted him,
he's giving his life story,
so he's not manufacturing, but
it's the framework of this.
I have to look at -- I was like,
wishing I had really looked
at this because I knew you were
going to be talking about Pope
and Johnson, but I don't.
>> Anthony Lee: Well, Johnson
expressed a lot of animosity,
non-suppressed, towards many of
the people that he wrote about.
In the Lives of the
Poets in particular,
but Pope is a special
case because --
and I talk about this in a
chapter in Dead Masters --
I think Pope, it's either Pope
or Dryden, but let's say Pope,
was Johnson's greatest
symbolic mentor.
When Johnson came
to London in 1737 he
and David Garrett took
turns riding a horse
from Litchfield to London.
Of course, Garrett became
famous almost overnight
and Johnson was very, had very
great animosity towards him
because of that.
But, in 1737 when he came
to London, Pope was god.
You know, Pope was -- Swift
was big, too, but Swift was
over in Dublin, but Pope
was the literary tyrant.
And Johnson became that and
he became that, in part,
by imitating Pope and, in part,
by competing against Pope.
You know? And so, he, Pope
wrote these, you know, epistles
and Horatian imitations
based upon Horace.
Well, Johnson did
similar things,
but did it with Juvenile
instead of the Vanity
of Human Wishes in London.
So he was kind of following
in a Pope trek or trail,
but he'd swerved and
he did it differently.
And, you know, his
descriptions of Pope, at times,
in The Life of Pope are almost
-- you know, we live in the age
of TMZ or these places that
flash people's private lives,
I mean it's everywhere --
but, Johnson was one of the
first people to do that.
He exposed that Pope
had to, basically,
sit on telephone books
to sit at the table
to look tall enough to eat.
I mean, he had very nakedly
-- I don't want to say brutal,
but it certainly took
him down a few notches.
And you could say that's
part of the dynamic
of being a symbolic
protégé to Pope is that --
but, I think those energies
were stronger in the '30s
and the '40s than they
were in the 1770s and '80s
when he's writing The Life.
Well, he published The Life
of the Poets in 1781, but,
I think the other explanation
is Johnson's adherence
to the truth.
You know? He wanted, not
necessarily to expose people,
but to be truthful about them,
and unflinchingly truthful.
And Boswell followed in
his master's footsteps
and took it to the next level.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: I do
know the whole tanner of Life
of Pope is rather --
but it's interesting
because what you're suggesting
with all of this intertextuality
because not just that
imitation being flowered,
but imitation being
authoritative and controlled
over -- so because if you look
at the elegant meaning, too,
you're going to change -- you're
not controlling the meaning,
you're going to change
every text interacting,
so you can't think,
once you read one text
and you're familiar
with the other text
and reading the other text and
speaking to it you can't think
of it in the same way.
That's right.
>> And you could say that taking
these allusions and quotations
and incorporating them
into one's own work,
you're taking their voice and
using it for your own purposes.
And not necessarily in a way
that honors the original
intention,
if that even is normal
or matters.
Someone else?
>> Speaker 2: Yeah, I had -- I
just wanted to elaborate on that
because I talk more about
18th century English poetry,
but I am interested in the whole
question of literary allusion
and [inaudible] and I found it
very fascinating, like you said,
in the beginning, that the work
of the Dictionary
is much longer.
And so it has this feature,
which to me reminded
of professional than
of common laws.
To which, to me, is actually
the Dictionary reading
of being related to the work
of him keeping a journal
of quotations, so that at the
same time we saw him using
that for compiling
the Dictionary,
which becomes a published book,
and the issue was quite a
supreme successor to the OED,
but at the same time,
clearly, using this --
whatever description you
want to use -- , [inaudible]
it collects, or a different
version of a collection
that [inaudible] with quotations
and then using it for your work.
I mean, you just had this
exchange about this modern idea
of paratext and allusion.
I mean you could make the
argument [inaudible] antiquity
in the Middle Ages people had
the idea of keeping a journal
by reading and then
using what you read
for your own production,
is basically the
underpinning of our rest
of understanding of education.
And it also works
outside the Western world,
but that's a different
kind of worlds to go into.
So, I'm not quite sure
whether we actually have this
[inaudible] take on something
that was well-established
that we wanted to show
that I have [inaudible],
but I have my homework.
By basically playing, but by
also misquoting or that sort
of thing where I'll use a
quotation expecting those
who are in the know to realize
that, for instance, [inaudible].
I mean what you had
at the beginning
of your presentation
was begun to, you know,
did people realize that,
actually, he had changed Pope
when he put it as
another in there.
Is that to sound [inaudible]
have literature circulating
in a circle of people that
-- everybody knows everybody
and everybody reads the same
books and everybody knows when,
I guess, [inaudible] and those
who don't get it,
they don't matter.
>> Anthony Lee: Yeah, it's
not like that anymore.
You raise a lot of good points.
I think Johnson -- I
think there's two points
to be made here about the
Dictionary and the Rambler --
Johnson was a great
advocate for keeping journals
and he kept journals throughout
his life and he advised Boswell
to do it, Hester Therell.
Unfortunately, before he
died, shortly before he died,
he created a bonfire and
destroyed most of them.
Because Sir John Hawkins took
one of them, took it home,
copied some stuff out of it
and brought it back
and he found out.
So, right before he died, so he
knew that he needed to get rid
of things that he didn't
want to be exposed about.
But he did keep something
called the Adversaria,
I think that's a Latin
term, and it's a collection
of little sketches
of ideas that he used
for his periodical essays for
the Adventurer and the Rambler
and only a few fragments
of these survive;
two of them in Boswell's
life and two of them
in the Hawkins' life --
two separate ones
-- so we have four.
And so, they show, incidentally,
one of them is for Adventurer 45
and the one for Rambler
196 shows
that he has the name Horace and
he used Horace for the motto.
So he did use this as a kind of
a commonplace book in, you know,
that tradition, but as far
as I know he didn't keep a
commonplace book throughout his
life and it's not clear
that he used this Adversaria
for every essay.
I mean, he had an
encyclopedic memory,
so he could draw upon
things, you know,
like Mozart composed
his symphonies
in his head before
he wrote them down.
Johnson did the same thing with
The Vanity of Human Wishes,
but the Dictionary
was a different story.
He actually went
through and read books
and underlined passages
and put little notes
and then had his anbuancies
[phonetic] scribble those down
and then they put them
in the Dictionary.
So I think we can say
with fair certainty
that the Dictionary
quotations were not taken
from a private journal or a
commonplace book, but were more
from his reading, but reading
directly towards the Dictionary.
And you raised a number of
other interesting points,
but I think someone
else had their hand up?
>> Eleanor Shevlin: When
does intertextuality
become plagiarism?
>> Anthony Lee: When does
it become plagiarism?
Well, it's interesting, that's
not something that people talked
about -- going out on dangerous
ground here, generalizing
about an area that's
not my province --
but in the Renaissance people
didn't know Shakespeare got most
of his plots from North,
Plutarc's North or Ovid or,
you know -- and nobody
seemed to care.
It's not until the 18th
century that the idea
of plagiarism becomes
a sensitive one,
and that's when the
idea of authority
over originality
also starts to pop
up with Edward Young's
conjectures
on original composition,
what was that, 1750s?
Well, Johnson read
that and he said,
well there's nothing original in
that book, we knew that already.
But that's often cited as a
precursor of romantic thinking,
which supposedly
postulates individual genius
and true literature as emanating
from a divine soul
communing with itself.
Of course, Wordsworth was
just as much of a craftsman,
and Coleridge, as Pope and
Johnson were, they just,
they did a better
job of hiding it, so.
That's a really good
question, you know,
it would require another talk
to unpack it, if not more.
I know books have been
published on that,
plagiarism in the Romantic
Period, in particular.
Eric probably knows
what they are.
>> Speaker 3: Yeah, I think
Coleridge was the great victim
of that kind of charge.
>> Anthony Lee: In biography and
literary, yeah, because of his
over commitment to
deadlines he couldn't meet.
Yeah, but that's almost sort
of a tragic story, there,
but he did it in a way
that made it so obvious
that he would get caught.
It's like -- but we're
kind of straying from --
>> Speaker 2: Seventh
edition [inaudible] traces
from antiquity to the
present day the idea
that human creativity can be
original and you need the idea
of human creativity being
original [inaudible].
That actually gives you the idea
of his individual mind
[inaudible] it's not just
me [inaudible].
I'm not sure about
the English edition.
I know about [inaudible]
so the idea is 1750s
as a breaking point.
>> Anthony Lee: 1750.
Well, Johnson wrote Rambler
143 in 1751 or '52 and it's
on plagiarism and he talks about
the issue of what we're talking
about here -- intertextuality
and plagiarism --
and he comes to the conclusion
that if you borrow a sentiment,
but appropriate it in such a
way that you make it your own,
then that's a creative act.
It's not the highest
creative act because he looked
down on imitation very much.
He thought all imitation
was poor.
He praised Milton.
He would have been the
greatest poet of all time,
except he came after Homer.
[Laughter]
Speaker 2:
>> To me, [inaudible]
actions have already created.
I mean, that's related to the
discussion you have [inaudible].
I mean, sort of these
[inaudible] how we get
around that.
>> Anthony Lee: In the
preface to The Fables,
Dryden has a quotation
about Ben Johnson
that I don't remember
the exact words,
but he said Ben Johnson steals
so -- he's like a monarch.
He steals so well,
he makes it his own.
[Laughter] You mentioned
classical literature,
if you look at Virgil --
where do most of his
things come from but Homer?
He -- if there had been no
Homer, there would be no Virgil.
At least not in the
form that we have it.
>> Speaker 2: I mean,
that's the idea.
That's the idea.
[Inaudible] Why did the classics
survive the Middle Ages?
Because you had [inaudible]
in order to be educated
and you sort of make
it your own.
So, the question
of how do you go
around that is exactly
the reason we come back
to [inaudible] because
you actually need
to make sure [inaudible]
depending on how literal.
[Laughter]
>> Speaker 4: A different
point of view,
[inaudible] I think there's a
problem with intertextuality.
I've been reading Austen
the last couple of weeks
and writing a publication
on persuasion.
And, in persuasion, what she
does is she [inaudible] she
never quotes it, but she
moves to it in such a way
that if you knew the
sonnet, you know what it is.
And the whole idea is that
in this sonnet [inaudible] is
always very depressed
and melancholy [inaudible]
there's going
to be no renewal of her joy.
And she says why can we not
have any renewal of joy?
[inaudible] I can't
have any renewal of joy.
But then, the next paragraph
you hear about the farmer
who doesn't care
about [inaudible]
and he's making the past.
Now, at that particular one, we
see her rewriting [inaudible]
and keeping her because
the novel is
in general very dark [inaudible]
also a cripple like [inaudible].
She also can't seem
to get any money
because she can't go to court.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] you know how far you
can go and how far you can't.
She says there are thousands
of poetical descriptions
of depression or
melancholy, but she points
out just the [inaudible] one.
Now, if you go to
Mansfield Park,
there she actually
quotes the line.
She quotes a line from
Isaac Browne about tobacco.
And she her character, Mary
Crawford, quoting this line.
Well, how are you going
to interpret that?
What Claudia Johnson does
[inaudible] is say the line
of Isaac Browne comes
[inaudible]
and Austen did not read the
poem in its original context.
She only meant to refer to
Isaac Browne in the [inaudible].
But if you know Isaac
Browne, you as a smart reader,
realize it's a rewrite
of the poet.
Now, [laughter], with Mansfield
Park, we see it as a rewrite
of Pope and you think
she's alluding to Pope.
You come to one interpretation
[inaudible] which is much darker
and much deeper and much broader
[inaudible] this book is.
If you say, oh no, [inaudible]
and she just wants us
to see Mary Crawford as
this superficial person
who is trying --
you get a very different,
you know, there's a question
of how far back -- and
this is an old question
because this comes
from my readings
of Richardson years ago.
Richardson has all these
quotes throughout [inaudible]
and they're deep and
tragic and they come
from all these tragedies.
Well, the unhappy fact
[inaudible] is almost everyone
comes to [inaudible] right.
So, it's a question
of how far back --
this is kind of a
serious question,
how far back we can peel
[inaudible] understand of it.
I think Austen in the persuasion
knows what she is doing,
that she knows she is
rewriting it so clear.
I think she knows she's using
Isaac Browne [inaudible]
but what she means by that and
how we [inaudible] we don't want
to start to have [inaudible] you
can have everything [inaudible]
and the work never stops.
So, there's a real problem of
how far the author may need
to peel intertextuality and then
how much it brings into the --
bring it into the work.
What are we going to bring in?
Are we going to bring
in just Charles Smith?
Are we going to bring in Byron?
Because after all Byron
[inaudible] melancholy later
in the book there is another
character who quotes Byron.
No. [Inaudible] a real crux
of how a reader should go
about dealing with these
intertextual books.
>> Anthony Lee: Well, I
think what you're left
with ultimately is the text.
How do you know what the
author's intention is?
And, so, you just have to
be like Detective Somerset
and gather your clues together
and make a strong case for --
I mean, I would ask
which line in Pope
and who was Pope
alluding to perhaps.
>> Speaker 4: That's right.
The reason that people tend not
to go back beyond
the Isaac Browne,
that's why I said to myself -
This is a new edition
[inaudible] I said
to myself [inaudible]
why didn't the person
quote Pope?
Well, because she is quoting
Claudia Johnson [inaudible].
So, I go back to Claudia
Johnson and I see that she,
very deliberately,
quotes [inaudible].
Before her, Chapman did.
Now, Chapman [inaudible].
There's a real crux of how
you're going to read the book,
how you're going to regard it
[inaudible] is very important,
but the problem is in
trying to understand
where it ends and
where it begins.
You see the same thing in films.
Films are intertextual
[inaudible]
and how far that can go.
>> These notes are part
of the current text.
>> Speaker 4: Well,
yes, they're all
in current text, that's right.
And, originally, of course,
you just had Isaac Browne
[inaudible] you have Sylvia
Johnson [inaudible].
[Laughter]
>> Anthony Lee: That
reminds me of something
that this young lady mentioned.
Johnson's edition of
Shakespeare, 1765,
he takes notes from earlier
commentators from [inaudible],
from Pope, Warburton,
and he incorporates them
into his notes with
his own comment.
So, you have this kind of
heteroglossia [phonetic]
of the voices that
are at the margins
of his Shakespeare edition,
these dialogical exchanges
amongst different critics.
And sometimes he'll
comment and say, you know,
enough, like, this is it.
I said I'll tell you what it is.
But, more often than not,
he just lets the reader sort
of fend for herself
or himself and try
to decide who is right here.
And that's another form
of intertextuality.
In my reading of Johnson,
that's not entirely dissimilar
to the use of authorities
in the Dictionary.
They are there and
the reader is invited
to do something with them.
>> Speaker 4: At some point
[inaudible] is there a text
in the house and you
need to decide what it is
that you have there is
all I'm really saying.
Another example I had
recently where another,
a new dispute [inaudible]
and the act was trying
to remember it.
But a new recent
[inaudible] genuine
and we should take
them seriously
and we should read them
[inaudible] other versions
of Hamlet.
So there comes a point where
you have to say, well no,
[inaudible] another
area of [inaudible].
Austen likes to hide her tracks.
That's one of the reasons you
have a hard time is she doesn't
want you to know all the
time who she's quoting.
>> Anthony Lee: I understand
your urge and information
and trying to arrive at
some sense of stability.
Eventually, if you're going
to write a paper, or a chapter
on something, you can't go
into this infinite regress.
I mean, you have to
decide what to include
and what not to include.
But that infinite regress is
exactly what I was suggesting is
the truth of it behind the
realm of the text that we have.
There is this universe
that I imagine possibly
and I think that's equally
exciting as well as trying
to provide some stable notion.
>> Speaker 4: That's
what I was thinking.
This is Johnson who quotes
Shakespeare [inaudible] there is
a textual corruption
[inaudible] and somebody came
up with the idea it means
just green tables [inaudible]
suddenly he's talking
about green tables
and was it Warburton or somebody
said [inaudible] it just fits.
So now we have this stable text.
[Laughter]
>> Anthony Lee: [Inaudible]
There's another question.
I will say this.
If you go back and look at
Edmond Malone and Johnson
and George Stevens,
and Warburton,
and look at their notes and
how they're arguing commas
and various things and
you look at a modern text,
say Bevington's edition and
it seems like it is stable.
But it's not.
It's not. That's an illusion
of the fixity of the print
on the text makes you think.
If you're an undergraduate,
this is what it is.
Not necessarily.
>> Speaker 5: This
makes me think
that the perceptive
student who is accused
of plagiarism might use
as a defense [laughter].
You only have to go back not
even very far [inaudible]
At what point do you -
>> Anthony Lee: I've
seen that happen.
Students from Africa, I've
seen them defend plagiarism
by saying that's how everything
is sort of a common --
they don't use these terms,
but a common oral discourse,
people circulating stories.
There is no proprietary
right on who is said
to own this or own that.
I don't know how
disingenuous that is,
but I've seen it in students.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: Well,
I think it would be hard.
I think, culturally,
there are various --
I don't know if anyone's --
I've had presentations when
I was a graduate student.
I was doing work in the
writing center about Russia.
The Soviet Union actually
wanting a lack of originality
and wanted this reproduction
of texts
and that students were
inclined to do that just the way
that students from
China would sometimes --
they could not put their
thesis or argument up front.
They would take pages to get
to because it was impolite
to comes -- so, it is
different cultural,
but what I was thinking
with regular, you know,
with another paper, I
think this is illegal.
I mean, with American
students writing,
and the idea of plagiarism.
A perceptive student that tried
to do something would
have created a work
that did just what Austen did
and made it his or her own.
I think it's very --
I don't think that
that's a problem
because I think even we
look at it today as the use
of how we were using
something to create a new work.
Because, I mean, that's just one
aspect besides the moral right
if you offend.
But in terms of legal.
>> Speaker 2: [Inaudible] that
I came as a graduate student
to the US, I found slightly
shocking [inaudible] I thought
that was common sense.
[inaudible] legal needed to be
mentioned in writing [inaudible]
you don't have in
European societies,
at least continental ones.
You know, you don't have to
go as far as China or Africa
in order to sort of come up with
[inaudible] circumstances there.
>> Speaker 4: I mean,
just talking absolutely.
But I'm saying [inaudible]
>> Sabrina Baron:
Any more questions?
>> Speaker 6: Perhaps we
could bring the whole subject
of intertextuality back to
stages [inaudible] and quote one
of his most famous lines
[inaudible] and goes like this.
[Inaudible] what's left to
us is to remember [laughter].
[ Applause ]
>> Sabrina Baron:
I couldn't help
but be thinking imitation
is the sincerest form
of flattery, trite
as that may be.
Thank you very much
for that interesting,
stimulating talk and discussion.
I hope you'll take
some time to look
at what the rare book folks
have brought out for us here
and then, if you'd like to
join us for drinks and dinner,
we'd be delighted to
have you come along.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.